herzlich willkommen in sallys welt ich
bin gerade mit meiner familie in der
türkei mit murat und mira und meine
eltern sind auch hier und wer uns
einfach gedacht wir können uns jetzt mal
eine auszeit denn das letzte jahr war
für uns alle ziemlich anstrengend ihr
habt ist er selber gemerkt ich habe ganz
viele videos gedreht ich auf viele
berichte gemacht ich war viel unterwegs
ich hab den online shop um den ich mich
natürlich auch ein bisschen kümmere und
es war einfach ziemlich viel
gerade jetzt im dezember habe ich ganz
viele videos gemacht für euch es war für
mich natürlich keine belastung denn ich
koche und backe ja auch gerne und ich
mache das ja auch total gerne ich wollte
einfach noch ganz viele rezepte für euch
machen gerade jetzt auch für die
weihnachtszeit für die winterzeit und
daraus sogar so dass ich teilweise acht
videos pro woche hatte weil ich einfach
nicht mehr wusste wann ich die videos
noch hochladen soll damit ich damit ihr
sie überhaupt noch nachmachen können und
deswegen habe ich gedacht nemo setzt die
auszeit gehen in die türkei
und meine eltern sind auch schon seit
längeren zeit hier und kommen jetzt aber
mit uns wieder zurück nach deutschland
das finde ich jetzt auch wieder ganz gut
weil ich sie sehr vermisst hatte und
jahres er mich ganz komisch ist wenn man
mit seinen eltern immer zusammen ist und
plötzlich sind sie dann drei vier monate
lang weg das ist natürlich eine
komplette umstellung und man vermisst
sie sehr und wie sie jetzt hier in der
schönen ferienanlage und zwar ist es
hier in magath in der nähe von antalya
side kennt ihr wahrscheinlich
je weicher auch schon im sommer da habe
ich ein restaurant besucht was ich euch
gezeigt hatte und jetzt sind wir wieder
hier ihr herz auch ein bisschen an
meiner stimme ich war natürlich auch
gleich erkältet habe auch ein herpes
gekriegt weil immer wenn ich entspannung
habe dann werde ich krank dann kommt der
körper zur ruhe
und jetzt sind wir hier seit ungefähr
einer woche
ich gucke ab und zu immer raus weil
draußen ist so schön ich zeige euch auch
gleich die aussicht das mache ich dann
gleich weg kurz gleich raus spazieren
dann zeige ich euch das und unsere
freunde sind auch das aber und sabine
ohne zimmer einfach hier in der wohnung
und haben uns auch gegen
tel entschieden weil ich erstens muss
ich gestehen auch in der türkei noch nie
ein hotel urlaub gemacht habe weil wenn
man als türke natürlich in die türkei
geht muss man verwandtschaft besuchen
und was heißt muss als einmal willst ja
auch weil man will ich auch seine
verwandte sehen man muss okay ich gebe
es zu
weil meine eltern haben hier ganz viele
verwandte und deswegen sind wir
eigentlich immer bei verwandten gewesen
und wanli im hotel und jetzt mir immer
so seit gewünscht aber mittlerweile bin
ich echt so ich bin gar nicht so hotel
mensch muss ich sagen so ein hotel fan
weil ich möchte lieber meine
privatsphäre haben deswegen sind wir
hier in der wohnung wir sind hier
alleine sind natürlich ganz viele
anderen wohnungen noch da sind glaube
ich 100 wohnungen komplett in der anlage
und hier gibt es dann leute die kaufen
sich eine wohnung das ist jetzt die
wohnung von unseren von unserer familie
bzw
von unseren freunden aber in der türkei
sie alle ist eh alles familie für uns
von daher familie und das ist einfach da
man kann sich so was auch mieten das
kostet so ungefähr 700 euro in der woche
was natürlich echt total günstig ist
wenn man als familie kommt weil wenn man
überlegt mal kuchen hotel da ist man
gleich mal mehrere tausend euro los und
hier ist einfach so du bist
selbstversorger ich habe meine küche
das zeige ich euch alles gleich rüber
aber da sprachen nicht so ganz
ordentlich steht er auch die babyflasche
rom kommen das ist okay das ist halt so
die küche und es reicht auf jeden fall
für uns wir haben hier drei schlafzimmer
in einem zimmer schlafen wie ihr im
anderen zimmer scharrel und sabine und
in dem dritten zimmer unsere kinder alle
zusammen in einem bett das ist total
cool und scharf an und so viele zeichen
auch gleich die des chefs kratzer wo ich
bei mir weil diese nämlich hat mit den
kindern in dem kinderparadies also im
bällebad und das sind die zwei freunde
von uns die übrigens auch meinen job
machen im schwarzwald also die
verpackung des alles und bestellen es
alles und immer wenn ihr kontakt zum
shop habt habt ihr praktisch kontakt zur
sabine oder zuschauer waren
oder hast du mir natürlich wenn ich die
e mails da halt beantworte und es sind
die zwei sind richtig gute freunde von
und das ist einfach jetzt richtig schön
jetzt nach der weihnachtszeit dann auch
zeit hier zu verbringen und ich glaube
ich zeige euch jetzt einfach mal ein
bisschen die anlage das erzählt wo ich
gerade bin ich war übrigens beim friseur
gott wer mich bei facebook und bei
instagram verfolgt der weiß es ich habe
es ja schon gezeigt ich bin total
unzufrieden
als ich habe meine haare schneiden
lassen und ich wollte eigentlich nur so
natürliche highlights haben so wie ich
eigentlich von natur aus habt weil meine
haare sind von natur aus unten immer
heller
und jetzt hat er mir strähnchen gemacht
aber ich lasse mir wieder raus machen
also sieht man jetzt hier vielleicht
dass sie total unnatürlich aus das
gefällt mir gar nicht und ich habe es
halt auch stufen drin und diese
natürlich etwas kürzer die stufen stern
mich auch ein bisschen weil ich wollte
sie hinten eigentlich nicht gestuft ich
habe jetzt ganz kurze haare das echt
unglaublich habe glaube ich 500 gramm
haare und naja die wachsen wieder
erwartet mit der farbe das geht gar
nicht das muss ich wieder wegmachen
lassen ich sage ich jetzt einfach mal
kurz die anlage und dann erzähle ich
euch noch kurz war es über das letzte
jahr
und dann möchte ich noch was von euch
wissen
bis gleich hier ist zum beispiel unsere
küche hier koche ich dann jeden tag mit
der sabine und wir packen auch hier und
frühstücken hier und es ist richtig
schön weil man einfach alles da hat ich
habe ja das ist alles sehr viel geschirr
wir sind super vorräte ja es reicht für
alles es gibt hier keine noch keine
küchenmaschine hier ja gut damals ein
bisserl zwiebel und so kleine süßigkeit
süßigkeiten habe ich bisher auch schon
kuchen gebacken mit seinem herrn
spielgerät ist natürlich viel länger ich
bin gar nicht mehr gewohnt irgendwie
aber es geht trotzdem und jetzt würde
ich sagen wir mal die schlafzimmer
angucken
hier zum beispiel unser schlafzimmer das
schlafe ich mir morath gemein
hier ist das bad noch mal nicht an liebe
ich dich da noch dann geht die lüftung
anschauen nicht so gut hat sich samira
die hände waschen wie ich sehen kann
ich stelle mich noch ganz vieles was ich
als zeigen muss dass die bettwäsche
herde ist so toll die habe ich jetzt
gekauft ich glaubte nämlich auch mit
nach deutschland
bettwäsche in der türkei zu kaufen ist
einfach genial also ich glaub ich hab
mir bettwäsche league oft als klamotten
hier war zum beispiel auch diese tolle
bettdecke mit dabei die nehme dann
abends immer mit aufs sofa zum kuscheln
es ist so schön einfach richtig schön da
haben es die in der türkei echt richtig
drauf ich noch hier ist eigentlich so
ein gästezimmer und da schlafen jetzt
unsere kinder eigentlich am abend und
hier das finde ich ganz genial
rumpelkammer hat eine waschmaschine drin
da ich halte mich ein wäschekorb keine
ahnung wie die das hier machen auf jeden
fall kann die wäsche waschen und einfach
zu machen und dann sieht man es einfach
nicht mehr aus dem auge lassen sinn
hier ist noch mal ein badezimmer das
gleiche eigentlich muss man nicht nur
mal zeigen
da sind jetzt eben schauen uns die liebe
drin
und hier ist auch im schlafzimmer das
kann ich jetzt aber nicht zeigen weil
die kleine schläft und ich glaube das
wohnzimmer ist aber nicht nur noch
zeigen
standen das war vorhin direkt drin aber
hier ist das esszimmer
da ist ein wasserspender weil wasser aus
dem wasserhahn das ist hier einfach viel
zu kalt ich viel zu kalkhaltig und
deswegen steht hier so ein gerät dann
muss man dass sich das wasser liefern
lassen
die bringt es auch her das sind ungefähr
19 liter wasser drin und es kostet fünf
lehrer das sind ungefähr war so zwei
euro also echt total nicht mal zwei euro
da kann ich hier einfach heißes und
kaltes wasser raus lassen und da unten
hat sogar noch ein kühlschrank aber die
benutze man als beispiel zu klein
und hier ist das wohnzimmer hier hat
auch ein fernseher auch mit deutschen
sendern mit türkischen mit allen sendern
eigentlich die man hier grad zu bekommen
kann und ich glaube jetzt zeige ich euch
mal wie es draußen aussieht wenn du hast
hier aus der terrasse raus geht dann
sieht man hier direkt in pool und die
anderen wohnungen unter vogel seht ihr
die zwei davon stehen und dann kann man
hier von der terrasse auch runter laufen
und so sieht die wohnung von außen aus
was natürlich nicht fehlen darf ist dem
ob das ist halt morath schwäbische
kehrwoche die macht daher wird immer
komisch angeguckt weil sonst keiner
irgendwie dasselbe macht das wird dann
immer gemacht von putz leuten aber der
murat macht es lieber selber erschallten
schwabe und den letzte auch wenn der
türkei raushängen es auch schön ich auch
und hier ist erholte hammer im sommer
drin schwimmen können jetzt natürlich zu
kalt also jetzt hat es ungefähr 20 grad
tagsüber so 18 bis 20 grad und es ist
mir natürlich zu kalt zum schwimmen aber
hier waren mainz noch mal das war echt
schön
und hier ist auch der ort an dem famila
in den voll gemacht hat und murat durch
das eintauchen und hilft anderen
geschissen nicht gemacht silly und ich
echte soll
der pool war zwei tage weg war genau
hatte moratti tauchen müssen und hat
hier so miraß kleine häufchen entfernt
hier ist sogar ein fitnessraum wo man
rein kann
hier war ich auch gestern abend aber
schon total der sportmuffel nach fünf
minuten bin ich wieder heim gegangen
ich mag diesen sport
ich hatte schon cool weil eigentlich
kann man den sport mache und direkt raus
gucken aber das ist einfach zu
anstrengend ist ob es werde traum meiner
schwester hier zu trainieren
sie trainiert gerne
eine krux die begleiten mich immer
überall hin auch wenn die türkei dann
haben wir aber moral ist laut direkt das
schwimmbad silber will
ist niemand drin kommt rein
hier scheint das hallenbad
jetzt ist schön war gestern abend was
ziemlich kalt aber ich glaube es war
weil stromausfall war in der ganzen
anlage und jetzt könnten wir einen
schöne stimmen geben
und hier ist es spieleparadies für die
kinder als wenn die kinder nicht draußen
spielen auch im gras auf dem rasen
spielen sie einfach hier
jetzt damit 15 uhr was ist so was wie
ein trampolin telepathe zudem mit karin
gleich die samira sie mir war sandro
macht spaß hier
die auch michael kinder und da können
sie einfach spielen und sich austoben
und sind einfach hier gut aufgehoben
also man kann auch draußen oder neben
anderen einfach trainieren und die
kinder sind dann hier das ist richtig
schön
vor allem wenn merken ja da sind selbst
richtig toll und die tür direkt
gegenüber eltern hierher und hier ist
ein campingplatz tisch und zum kicker
und tischkicker
das heißt hier können sich dann die
erwachsenen oder jugendlichen aufhalten
und könne jedoch einfach wissen den
abend verbringen muss der ball komm -rat
bezogene runde
der kopf von hawke und hier sprach ein
restaurant das hat jetzt zwar grad zu
weil einfach grad nicht die saison ist
im april wird er wieder eröffnet haben
wir auch im sommer schon gegessen hier
kann man einfach richtig gut und günstig
auch essen du kannst hier frühstücken
mittagessen abendessen
du kriegst hier immer frische limonade
man sieht es auch hier plötzlich so dass
sich limonaden gefäß und das ist
natürlich richtig cool wenn du dann im
sommer hier abgelegt und war schnell
selbst gemachter limonade echt richtig
schön und ich glaube jetzt habe ich euch
so die ganze anlage mal gezeigt und
jetzt gehen wir einfach mal wieder rein
oder wieder rein
ihr prinz ihn ihr noch so ein paar
palmen eigentliche party in der türkei
nichts zu suchen
aber das wird er an gepflanzt weil sie
einfach nach urlaub aussieht und so
wissel so wissel karibischen karibik
also ist es ist hier kein club urlaub
kein hotel urlaub sondern wir sind hier
einfach in unserer wohnung drin und
wohnen da essen da und es ist aber auch
so dass wir natürlich auch die anlage
hier verlassen so schön sie auch ist
aber möglich natürlich auch ein bisschen
mensch und bleibt und kultur
kennenlernen und das machen wir hier
wir können hier einfach vorne entweder
in so ein bus einsteigen in den bus der
uns dann in die stadt fährt
aber wir haben zum beispiel ein auto
gemietet für 15 euro am tag
das ist wirklich ein super preis mit
auto muss einfach noch ein bisschen rein
teil und kann stand einfach von a nach b
kommen
wir brauchen etwa fünf minuten mit dem
auto in die stadt rein ökonomisch oder
ans meer natürlich auch und das ist
wirklich toll aber ich würde sagen das
zeige ich euch einfach in meinem
nächsten freien video wird dann das
video über die türkei mache und da
erkläre ich alles noch magazin
so ihr habt jetzt die anlage gesehen
also selbst wenn wir jetzt draußen im
freibad nicht schwimmen können konnten
wir wenigstens im hallenbad ein bisschen
schwimmen und ich muss auch dazu sagen
wir haben uns jetzt den urlaub gegönnt
wir war also wir sind jetzt fast sieben
jahre verheiratet
wir sind zehn jahre zusammen und fahren
und jahr falls sie noch verheiratet im
juni und sich erst unser zweiter urlaub
also wir waren einmal zusammen im urlaub
als ich schwanger war und das war jetzt
der dritte eigentlich also im sommer
manöver nochmal und das ist dieses mal
und es war echte dritte urlaub erst
murata ich glaube recht schön und denkt
es muss man sich auch mal können und bei
uns was früher aber auch so als mit
meinen eltern wir waren nicht jedes jahr
im urlaub das war bei uns
ich war mit meinen eltern nur dreimal in
der türkei also innerhalb von 18 jahren
ich habe alle sechs jahre nur meine
verwandtschaft gesehen und waren alle
sechs jahren im urlaub also das muss man
auch dazu sagen dass ihr jetzt denkt ich
mache jeden sommer urlaub muss man
natürlich auch arbeiten dafür ist ja
klar ich möchte es ganz kurz noch über
meinen vergangenes jahr sprechen also
über das jahr 2014 das war bei mir
natürlich sehr ereignisreich es war auch
sehr anstrengend ich hab' war bis juli
noch mein referendariat macht an der
grund an der grundschule
ich hatte anfang des jahres also im
frühjahr meine prüfungen
das war glaube ich die stressigste zeit
in meinem ganzen leben prüfungen zu
machen nebenher meine youtube videos zu
machen
die natürlich auch als auszeit genutzt
habe weil mir das natürlich sehr viel
spaß macht und nebenher mich noch um die
familie zu kümmern und es wird natürlich
alles nicht funktionieren hätte ich
jetzt nicht mein mann hinter mir meine
familie hinter mir
die sich natürlich immer um mich kümmert
auch und mich dabei unterstützt und ich
habe dieses jahr so viele videos gemacht
wie glaube ich noch nie waren ganz viele
videos dabei die viele positive
resonanzen auch bekommen haben
ich hab das wichtigste video für mich
war glaube ich in diesem jahr mein video
über die flüchtlinge
ich habe in meiner ganzen youtube
karriere sage ich jetzt mal bisher noch
nie in video gehabt was so viele
positive bewertungen bekommen hat was
aber auch noch nie so viele negative
bewertungen bekommen
also das war wirklich ein video das hat
auch ganz viele aufrufe und da war auch
ganz viel diskussionen darüber da waren
ganz viele kommentare aber mir war es
wichtig das zu machen weil ich finde
sich einfach eine problematik gewesen
weil die ein erstes mal viele nicht
kannten
es gab viele menschen die nicht wussten
dass jetzt gerade flüchtlinge nach
deutschland kommen es gab viele jahre
weggesehen haben und viele die sich
dagegen gewehrt haben und ich fand es
einfach wichtig für mich ein video
darüber zu machen weil ich wollte
einfach helfen und ich muss auch dazu
sagen wir haben echt viel erreicht es
kam ganz viel hilfe von euch
wir haben ganz viele spenden gesammelt
werden viele kleidung gesammelt
spielsachen und es kam es dort an
und das fand ich einfach super dass er
mich da auch total unterstützt habt und
deswegen finde ich war es auch ein
richtiges video und zwar eine richtige
entscheidung des zu machen
es war sowie pakete da war alles nur
folgen gar nicht mehr sortiert
also noch tausendmal dank dass sie uns
alle mit herz hat und wir werden noch
weiterhin darüber berichten und ich
gucke das fenster weil der markt hat da
steht dann zeigen euch auch gleich
richtig frei die frechener ist es ich
mache da kommt gleich wir hören uns gott
sagen geht's nicht da steht noch vor der
terrasse war immer da so von der
schwäbischen alb der kommt auch daher wo
ich herkomme
da hätte ich noch nicht
instanz ganzen kann ja ein ganz lieber
wissen auch hier im urlaub das richtig
wir haben alles probleme dürfen nicht
aufnehmen also wir dürfen kein
bildmaterial verwenden
genau das ist mein problem ich wollte
euch ein video noch darüber machen wo
eure hilfe angekommen ist eben weil bei
in der flüchtlingsunterkunft in
waghäusel aber ich darf da nicht filmen
also da haben wir ganz arg probleme
bekommen weil also würde ich das mit
meiner kamera auftauchen und filmen dann
das wer hat nicht so gut für mich weil
das darf man halt nicht allein schon
wegen den persönlichkeitsrechten und
einfach die verwaltung dort möchte es
auch nicht was ich teilweise auch
verstehen kann aber ich finds schade
weil ich euch nicht zeigen kann
aber ich denke wir haben da eine familie
kennengelernt da moses und seine frau
vielleicht kommt jemand zu uns um ein
video mit denen die sind richtig süß hat
auch gerade ein kind bekommen und ich
freue mich schon die beiden oder die
drei wieder zu sehen oder die vier teams
zu viert vistamar kennt der schon von
myvideo und er mag ich gekommen da muss
jetzt auch gleich wieder gehen der ganz
kurzen draht und mehr aufzubringen
ganz genau
es ist ganz cool weit ich hab nämlich
meiner mama aus deutschland auch meine
sachen mitgebracht
wiewohl das video nicht gesehen
ach so stimmt also wer denn mag nicht
kennt der mag der verkauft eben diese
koch blumen und das ganze silikon
geschätzt habe ich alles bei ihm gekauft
weil ich der markt
und weil er einfach die besten sachen
ganz genau gespart der markt muss jetzt
los weil die zwei frauen hatten schon an
der tür und mache meine beiden frauen
und ihr machen die tage da mal ein
cooles video kommt die tage vorbei und
da bin ich auch ausgeschlafen ausgeruht
und frisch und dann machen wir ein
schönes video
ich habe geschlafen wort ich habe urlaub
und ich entspannen mich versuche ich es
zumindestens deswegen sehe ich jetzt
einfach so müde aus aber egal wenn
entlassen werden könnte die stadt das
schöne ist bei mir ändert sich das wenn
ich ausgeschlafen bin beim also das war
jetzt der mag ihr seht da ist richtig
lustig und ich finds echt super dass er
da ist er unsere freunde sind nämlich
auch da hat der levin ist auch da bei
schreiber nicht da ich glaubte ich
daheim das schläft noch oder so aber ich
zeige euch den auf jeden fall in meinem
türkei video weil ich mache noch so ein
video was ich je gemacht habe und ich
zeige euch da auch ausschnitte was sich
im sommerurlaub je gemacht habe habe ich
nehms material da aber ich habe das
video nicht hochgeladen
magdeburg also ihr habt gesehen ich habe
ganz viele videos gemacht im dezember
und komplett in diesem jahr
ich würde jetzt gerne von euch wissen
habt ihr vielleicht ein lieblings video
von mir aus dem jahr 2014 habt ihr
lieblingsrezept oder was habe ich euch
zum beispiel beigebracht was konnte
etwas kannte tier noch nicht was war neu
für euch das wird mich jetzt sehr
interessieren einfach damit ich auch
weiß was ich im nächsten jahr noch so
alles machen könnte
was kann ich vielleicht besser machen
was gefällt euch nicht so gut oder was
gefällt euch richtig gut was soll ich
weitermachen und vor allen dingen
wünsche ich mir gerne
dass ihr mir schreibt was ihr gerne noch
für wünsche habe für das jahr 2015 von
mehr also video mäßig was ich richtig
toll fand in diesem jahr war dass ich
nicht nur einfach auf youtube für euch
da war sondern ich hatte ja auch meine
back aktionen im globus dann hatte ich
meinen weihnachtsmarkt war ich so meine
kinder backaktion und da konnte ich
einfach ganz viele meiner zuschauer
kennen lernen
mit einigen habe ich sogar noch so ganz
viel kontakt ich hatte die aktion dass
ich in der sap arena beim pilgern ceylan
war mit etwa 20 zuschauern und ich
find's einfach schön euch auch kennen zu
lernen
das möchte ich nächstes jahr auch gern
machen da möchte ich auch mal ein paar
städte besuchen
auch in österreich und in der schweiz da
war ich nämlich noch nie und da werde
ich ganz oft danach gefragt das mache
ich auch auf jeden fall
und eben frühjahr wird auch mein job im
globus in wiesental eröffnen
da freue ich mich richtig drauf das wird
so unser nächstes großes projekt da gibt
es dann eben auch die sachen aus meinem
online shop zu kaufen aber dass ich
nicht nur da damit man eben sachen aus
dem shop bekommt sondern dass man auch
mich sieht und ich möchte koch und
backkurse geben das heißt dann kann ich
euch auch richtig tipps und tricks
zeigen weil ich kann euch dann einfach
auf die finger schauen und sehen dass
oder das könntest du besser machen oder
da kannst du genauso weitermachen
und ich denke da ist an der persönliche
kontakt da und da freue ich mich richtig
drauf an meinem backbuch bin ich auch
dran aber ich möchte natürlich das was
besonderes wird und deswegen lasse ich
mir da einfach noch ein bisschen zeit
und sammeln ein paar rezepte und ideen
und möchte auch natürlich dass es vom
optischen her richtig toll wird und ich
glaube meine videos laufen ja gerade auf
baden tv
das ist ein regionaler sender bei uns
und das will ich auch ganz gut so weil
ich einfach meine videos weiterhin zu
machen möchte ich möchte auch natürlich
möchte ich eine back sendung oder eine
kochsendung das war mein absoluter traum
aber ich fühle dass es so eine wird wie
ich es möchte und nicht wie ein großes
sender des von mir haben möchte mit
drehbuch und konzept in allem ich will
einfach so bleiben wie ich bin
wird vielleicht gern so ein paar
zuschauer einladen darf du darfst
genauso möchte ich so möchte ich bleiben
und deswegen arbeit gibt's erstmal damit
baden tv weiter zusammen
die dürfen meine videos ausstrahlen und
das ist auch richtig toll denn ich kann
auch mit dem team ab und zu auf achse
gehen auf tour gehen und dann ein paar
richtig coole filme drehen das machen
wir auch im nächsten jahr weil da was
wirklich schon so es waren schon einige
private sender auch da die kennt ihr
auch alle darf nur die namen nicht
nennen oder möchte auch gar nicht die
mir einfach ein konzept vorgeschlagen
haben
und ich konnte aber nicht annehmen weil
es nämlich einfach keine bugs sendung
gewesen wäre sondern eher eine show und
ich meine im deutschen fernsehen gibt es
wirklich ganz viele bugs kochshows die
aber meiner meinung nach nichts dem
backen zu tun haben sondern einfach
entweder die menschen dort die
kandidaten bloßstellen oder einfach zu
viel drama machen und so viele
geschichten erfinden und ich finde das
passt einfach nicht zu mir
und deswegen bleibe ich beim ein
badisches änderbar baden tv und mache
meine videos so wie ich sie und jetzt
kamen mir doch eine idee im urlaub und
zwar beim rat vorgeschlagen ich könnte
auch demokrat auch in instagram profil
machen irgendwie sallys torten welt
morath und könnt da einfach auch immer
wieder sachen posten denn der hat auch
ab und zu das bedürfnis dazu immer rein
zu gucken und will immer ganz sachen
schreiben das habe ich mal war das kann
ich nicht machen
und vielleicht wäre es ja auch was was
euch gefallen würde schreibt es mir
einfach in die kommentare
schreibt mir einfach mal das mit dem
lieblingsrezept mit dem lieblingsvideo
mit euren wünschen für 2015 und ich
würde sagen ich wünsche euch allen jetzt
schon mal einen guten rutsch ins neue
jahr
ich hoffe dass er schön feiert oder
einfach zu hause schön zeit wir werden
zusammen mit unseren freunden essen
gehen ganz gemütlich und dann den abend
zu hause verbringen denke ich machen ich
freue mich auf jeden fall aufs neue jahr
freue mich auf viele weitere rezepte und
freue mich einfach auf euer feedback
ich wünsche euch noch als alles gute und
wir sehen uns ganz bald schon wieder im
neuen jahr bis dann
der borat krieg ein mikrofon weil dann
redet dann noch mehr
deswegen aber ich kriege neues mikrofon
also das ist echt das geht gar nicht